[Music]
and decade-long beef news submitted by
nyle style nick cannon released a diss
track against Eminem Oh No Nick Cannon
yeah I heard about this they're going
back and forth I don't know it's in much
are you serious
Kenneth thought was variety were no
rapper right no he was kind of a
definitely rap rap soda Wilin out but he
also here maybe two apples I don't like
that kind of rap not like you know not
in a new you know I mean like I mean yes
Eminem said something about well you
gonna read it cuz I don't want to
swallow you I just said up well for
starters I would like to mention I'm so
sad Nicki is not here but she's in the
Bahamas cuz she would [ __ ] love this
story anyway so the beef starts back in
May 2009 mmm yeah so he didn't it Kenan
and Maury carry on his bagpipes from
Baghdad song and that's where he says
this line that says Nick Cannon you
prick I wish you luck with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] every minute there's a sucker born
snuck up on Malik I made it the
[ __ ] stuck on his you guys can
listen to it I'm fortunate anyway so I
was a really cool semmen him I know if
you really is imagination
you're kind of yeah I don't even try why
do you want to disrespect Eminem like
that so anyway so then um then in June
2009 Mariah drops obsessed guys remember
that song yeah why so obsessed with me
see that one I could I could try mmm
that was there okay anyone sounded more
like a so that song and then in the
video
it's like mariah is portrayed as like
eminem look-alike and so in July 2009
Eminem responds with the warning which
is like a retaliation to obsessed
and and then in September 2010 Nick
Cannon drops Eminem diss track I'm a
Slick Rick believe it I didn't even know
that existed either and then I listened
to it for the story and I'm like this
bug away no wonder no one hurt I didn't
even know there was beef going on yes I
remember when obsessed came out and
everyone was like oh you know it's about
him it's about I do let the Mariah I was
like I thought that's what the biggest
lipid was was like but you know it
wasn't right anymore so what's your was
she oh yeah by the way to make it more
clear in case you don't know as to why
they have a beef is because Eminem is
claiming that he was in a sort of
relationship with Mariah for six months
but then in one of his diss tracks he
does mention that he only lets she only
let him [ __ ] once and he actually
prematurely he's a great Ally
self-deprecating humor you really can so
but then he does say that right and so
when he came out with bagpipes from
Baghdad they had just Mariah and Nick
had just gotten married so they were
newlyweds when that song came out so
Eminem is kind of viewed as like oh he
was salty he still had a thing for her
sorta okay that's what he's dissing
their their marriage and then that's
when Maya came out with obsessed I
should have told the story that way
sorry I skipped all that important [ __ ]
anyway so then January 2016
Nick invites Eminem on wild and out he
ends up tweeting everybody knows I would
love Eminem to be on well now y'all go
convinced Marshall that is saying that
didn't seem sincere there's a real
invite is you just text them personally
all I have is you having a tear each
other yeah you don't need to make it out
publicly a picture Eminem on Walden out
though yeah it's it's kind of childish
it's a different level yeah but this
thing would be dope it's like when you
saw emmaandemma eight now you didn't
know what's bad but it's [ __ ]
phenomenal alright and Eminem seems like
a funny guy yeah I don't think you would
like I think you would just it would be
such a child's play with him yeah there
yeah yeah what do you say will be dealt
to see him in concert yeah so then in
June that same year in 2016
Nick Cannon ends up saying on this radio
show and UK that he's ready to battle
Eminem in the ring as I boxing fight oh
yeah like a fight so he was he was
saying something about like $100,000 he
wanted to fight him but Evan I've never
addressed that him and I was like I'm
tired now grow or all so I think that's
where Nick will have him is in the
boxing yeah he's got reach me okay to
you was like I know I can't out wrap you
but I could kick your ass right yeah so
that's some typical macho [ __ ] that was
like all right but I bet I beat your ass
though like it was like family you give
me a concussion but we're you playing
ball or something yeah so then September
of this year
Nick Cannon opens up about his Eminem
beef on TI's podcast oh gosh he ends up
saying he revealed it's like a
five-minute clip and he ends up saying
that Nick Cannon wrote a long-ass letter
pretty much saying quote I respect you
as an artist I'm actually a fan I think
you're one of the best to ever do it but
from man to man you you're you're
talking you talking out of pocket to my
wife you've got to be held accountable
for that so I I need to see you face to
face so then he was still mad so then he
was saying that he was just explaining
the beef back then about like like
listen you disrespected my wife that's
not okay it's not even your wife anymore
I think in retrospect yeah in retrospect
exactly so you're just saying like this
is where my head was I was trying to
like meet up with him he's like I hit up
managers I hit up his camp and like you
know they they have mutual friends and
[ __ ] but that nothing ever came about it
and um he's a battle rapper he's gonna
talk his [ __ ] that's his craft right so
when people take it personal deep that's
kind of weird especially cuz Nick Cannon
he raps too and he does battles yeah but
that's for Nick Cannon he was like well
I gotta show my wife I'm a man
yeah I know for her and I gotta stand up
for myself and then tea I was saying he
was like well Nick you were kind of like
collateral damage there cuz he was
trying to attack Mariah because I they
had a thing but then Nick is like sure
but like with Drake and push-ups or the
beefing all of you I think that was it
was last year they started be fit and
Drake said uh I'll make them things ring
on you like Virginia something whatever
his last name is he was talking about
because pushing had just got married to
a young lady named Virginia whatever
that last name is and so once you break
someone's wife into it it's like all
gloves are off right so the next song
was when he came out that he came at
like your dad where Steve Harvey suits
your mama love your home your best
friend is the time-bar I'm waiting to
die he looked sick sick sick how much
time that boy got laughing tick tick
tick
like everything he said and then he said
you have a son that you've been hiding
from the world let that boy come home
right and love that woman cuz she was
like a video vixen type chick yeah so
Drake had a whole line with adidas he
was supposed to be launched in with the
coming out of his son but when push you
put that ends up ruined everything
he was like once you mentioned my wife
all gloves off they don't matter we both
rappers but it's the same playing field
right it's wrapped arrest mm-hmm so that
makes sense
versus somebody wanting to take in it
like take a piss or whatever your true
but I'm sure if after he dropped there
with that record
I'm sure if Drake and pushy had been in
the same place together like a day later
I'm sure he would have possibly came to
blows oh no just lost it like it's not
just like you're not attacking my
credibility as a rap you're not saying
you know he was saying like you got
somebody to write your raps for you like
you like you coming at my family you
would say you were trying to attack my
integrity as a man so now you got to see
me so what was he really talking about
his wife or was that it like it was just
a double entendre that he did this is a
good wordplay he wasn't really saying
he's just like I make a ring on you like
Virginia like kind of like hell hawk
thought that biggie shot him because he
made that song who shot you well yes but
that song was made after yeah hot dog
biggie shot him because
biggie was at the studio he showed up at
the studio
at that part got shot it that song came
out he thought that was for him yeah but
that I suppose that song was already
made it was already yeah that's yeah and
it was like a like same thing like it
was an accident or whatever or it could
be could be to continue this beef then
in December of 2019 in this very same
month Eminem this is Nick Cannon on Fat
Joe's new album on the so the album new
albums called family ties and in one of
the songs he ends up it's called Lord of
love
hands up dissing the campus and even Fat
Joe like he had made a statement about
it saying like man Eminem is on this new
thing like you you he hasn't been this
dressed disrespectful in a long time
like he was already prepping the masses
for his verse and so he ends up saying
that Nick Cannon was still whipped by
his ex-wife and he was inferior to him
and he ends up saying that he's like
almost got Mike I think we're all
inferior to Mariah
I saw her house I saw how it was
inferior to Eminem oh yeah so then he
ends up saying almost got my caboose
kicked full quit you ain't gonna do [ __ ]
I let her chop my balls off too for I
lost to you Nick
so he was saying that he ended up
getting that that [ __ ] got him neutered
try to tell him this chick some nut job
before he got his jewels clip that's
almost seems like he's offering an olive
branch though like hey we were both
victims of this crazy I tried it warned
you but you didn't [ __ ] listen I mean
I was too late anyway
but then Nick comes back with two diss
tracks and when it is called the
invitation and the other ones called
pray for him and like for example one of
them says we don't have time to pray for
him is actually for him it's for him so
please pray for me I know in in the
invitation he said so Suge Knight is
calling Eminem a [ __ ] and then he
good night with us back from jail jail
from jail and then he ends up saying
call him somebody get Helio and this is
Nick Cannon call him somebody get Haley
and that other kid you raising that
ain't even your baby because he has two
other daughters that he adopted Eminem
adopted and then he says my baby mama
killed you off a decade ago you're still
crying about it [ __ ] now who really the
ho and then Eminem comes back on Twitter
and said yeah because in the invitation
where's with Mariah and all of this he
refers to frickin holiday dude signup
married holidays you should probably is
she feeling over all that living in her
castle like actual princess
so it's [ __ ] tight making the best
Christmas song in the world mmm so then
he ends up so Nick Cannon also brings up
this allegation that M chauffeur saw him
it's all Eminem engaged in a sexual
activity with another man and then
Eminem ends up tweeting you mad bro stop
lying on my dick I never had I never
even had a chauffeur you bougie as [ __ ]
he's like that's my boyfriend not my
shelf apology Nicholas you've made my
gardener so jealous like this beef is
like it is I'm going for no reason at
all like if it was new claims or
something like that it would be probably
interesting but like he's a grown man
they're both grown he's a grown man you
know I mean that's an old picture of you
naked Mariah have been divorced for
years now like to bring it back up the
scenes pointless and therefore like Nick
likes for you to make a diss record
people have to want to listen to a
record period like if you actually came
out and was like this [ __ ] was so bad I
should kick your ass so telling mccannon
like how could you even come up against
Eminem he's like I've never seen anyone
actually you know come up is he trying
to like sell something right usually
that's what happens when you're
something like this like is you have
album coming out
the last the last season last season
Wilin out this is gonna be the last one
so maybe but it no it's not because life
is like a corny doing this like this it
doesn't people are gonna be like you
never like yo this they just corner
Barbara you can't go against Eminem one
will pick the wrong guy you picked the
wrong guy to go that I agree with that
but when else were we talking about Nick
enemy when else would did was he even
right wallet out while about has made no
yeah it hasn't reached me but this
reached me I'm like oh [ __ ] are you
gonna watch long enough I don't know
just reach you by default of a job it
didn't reach you like organically cuz I
reach me too but then it made me go on
they can in some corner than ever long
enough see
[Music]
[Music]